this week it was announced elon musk
moved his primary residence from
california
to texas with this relocation musk
jeff bezos and bill gates the three
richest people in america
live where they do not have to pay state
income taxes
musk's move was expected as he had
clashed with california officials over
the state's coronavirus restrictions
suing alameda county and threatening to
move tesla out of state after its
factory was not allowed to reopen
as for bezos and gates they both reside
in washington state
which does not collect state income
taxes washington
and texas are two of nine states that
don't collect
income tax the rest are alaska florida
nevada new hampshire south dakota
tennessee
and wyoming of course musk is not the
only billionaire to move for tax reasons
president trump moved his official
residence from new york to florida in
october 2019
and wall street titans carl icahn and
paul singer also recently moved their
hedge funds to the sunshine state
american hedge fund billionaire john
arnold pointed out on twitter that
california's 13.3 percent capital gains
tax
the country's highest technically falls
to zero when high earners like musk
decide to leave